Now that Marvel Studios has confirmed that
Mahershala Ali will lead the Blade reboot
as Eric Brooks, artists and Photoshop experts
have created edits and illustrations imagining
what Ali could look like as the Daywalker.
Here's a glimpse at some of the best.
Using a poster of Mahershala Ali as the devious
Vector in Alita: Battle Angel, artist @mizuriofficial
whipped up a cool edit of what the actor might
look like as Blade.
Ali's Blade rocks black sunglasses and an
all-black suit, holding a massive sword ready
to slice and dice any vampires that come his
way.
Also inspired by Mahershala Ali's performance
as Vector in Alita: Battle Angel, popular
digital artist and Photoshop master @Bosslogic
created an edit of what the Oscar-winner could
look like as Blade.
We can't tell what's more impressive: Bosslogic's
work, or that he created the edit five months
before Ali was announced as the new Blade.
"Are you from the future?”
“Well, he is.
I'm not.”
“That's brilliant.
Do they still have sandwiches there?"
When Marvel announced that a Blade reboot
was happening with Ali taking the lead as
Eric Brooks, Goldie Arver got to work illustrating
some seriously stunning concept art and shared
the results on her Instagram.
Her illustrations depict Ali's Blade in a
full costume and with fangs, with a close-up
shot of him looking head-on at the camera
with red sunglasses.
Arver also shared a standalone version of
the front-facing illustration.
In digital artist Montajes Asgaya's rendition
of Mahershala Ali's Blade, the character wears
his hair in a hi-top fade style that shows
off his head and neck tattoos, and holds his
weapon of choice gracefully in his hand.
Against a deep red background, Blade looks
determined, time-hardened, and totally badass.
“Ooh, ooooh, so exciting."
Omar Rios imagines that when Mahershala Ali
takes the blade to become the new Eric Brooks,
he'll get more than just his hands dirty.
On his Instagram page @ozone719, Rios shared
a full-color and a black-and-white illustration
that shows Ali's Blade with multiple weapons
and a bulletproof vest that's covered in blood.
Another person who predicted Marvel Studios
would cast Mahershala Ali as the famous Daywalker
was artist and illustrator Masood Tahir.
Uploading his striking original artwork on
his Instagram @mastahgram, Tahir shared an
eye-catching black-and-red-soaked illustration
of what Ali could look like when he makes
his Marvel Cinematic Universe debut.
It's bound to put a smile on anyone's face.
[Blade smiles, then stops smiling.]
On his Instagram account @ultraraw26, Yadvender
Singh Rana made a piece of art that shows
Ali's Blade with an intense look on his face,
staring someone down from behind red-lensed
glasses as he reaches for the weapon on his
back.
If that doesn't scream Blade, we don't know
what does.
Artist Camille Vialet imagined that Mahershala
Ali's iteration of Blade will hold nothing
back in the forthcoming reboot.
On her Instagram account, @cvialet_art, Vialet
shared her vision of the actor in the role:
kneeling on the ground, wearing a smug smirk
on his face as enemies aim their weapons directly
at his chest, shoulder, and leg.
It's easy to imagine him getting ready to
devastate his enemies with a perfect one liner.
You know, something like…
"Some motherf---ers are always trying to ice
skate uphill."
Empire Design art director Olly Gibbs took
an oh-so-sleek approach with his artwork depicting
what Mahershala Ali might look like as Blade
on his Twitter.
Against a bright red background, Ali's Blade
looks dramatically to his right while resting
his gun against his shoulder and neck.
Jackson Caspersz created a beautiful illustration
of Mahershala Ali as Blade, while a number
of enemies lurk in the background.
The picture appears to depict a scene just
seconds before an awesome rooftop vampire
fight scene, one where the vampires learn
a very important lesson:
"There are worse things out tonight than vampires.”
“Like what?”
“Like me."
Artist @apexform was so impressed with Ali's
casting as Blade that they created an ultra-cool
edit in which Ali's version of Blade has red
eyes, two blades on his back, and loads of
tattoos.
Whatever Ali's Blade looks like in the upcoming
film, one thing's for sure.
"You tell him it's open season on all suckheads."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.